you know I guess one person can make a
difference
enough said
it's funny the killer cameos I've
suddenly become known as the king of the
cabbage king of the Cameo I have no
competition the only idiot who does
those all the time but they're fun I
love doing them and I'm very pleased
that people ask me to do them
imitation sir I should be on that list
name Stanley yeah welcome back to the
Baxter dr. Richards I got the usual for
you good to have you back sir
egg damn should have paid those parking
tickets oh no my sandwich was in there
well at least now I'll be able to park
in San Francisco oh man I just stole his
car thank God it's a rental well looks
like I'm walking oh geez all my coupons
were in there talk about diminishing
returns oh man everything is shrinking
on me that was the very first thing we
shot on a man to wasp but you felt like
a good luck charm so we you know we
devised in the movie sort of where we
wanted Stan's cameo to be and I think
there's a thing with all the Marvel
directors we want to try and outdo the
other directors Stan Lee cameo so we had
a bunch of funny lines that sort of
keyed out that scene and we just feed
them to stand off and you can probably
hear me off-camera like being in line to
him and he delivers them and really we
sort of we test different versions in
line
see which one gets the biggest laugh
well the 60s were fun but now I'm paying
for it hey fellas hey wait where are you
going hey you were supposed to be my
lift home how will I get out of here hey
on G I've got so many more stories to
tell ah guys oh gee